one of the quotes on your imdb page is
evolve study your strategies versus
results and adjust course
pay attention to what works for your
peers and those who have come before
ask for advice from experienced
filmmakers definitely do not keep
pursuing a course of action that is
producing no results or poor results
and i've seen so many people ruin their
careers because they were inflexible
and unable to adapt yeah so first off
did you is that is that one of your sort
of mottos did you read that somewhere
that's me that's you that's honest i
mean that's just say that and i picture
those people in my head i'm not gonna
tell you who they are
right thank you okay
but but so that's like the 30 years
culmination
of of from sleeping on the egg crate to
working on you know high-end music
videos and film and
and seeing you know you know
the ability to
[Music]
grow and adapt and revise
your model inside your head
the more you're malleable the more
you're liable for success
the more that you're rigid the more that
you're
right the more that you have a liability
for failure
because the world none of us
know how the world works we have clues
we have ideas we have experiences based
on our past and things that people tell
us
but as humans our perceptions are not
we don't perceive reality you know our
sensory organs
give us you know photons and audio
vibrations
that go into the circuitry of our brains
and our biology manipulates it
and and and just the the subtleties in
the human
psyche and cross
wires or whatever it is none of us
looks at anything a hundred percent
objectively though we may
think we do we color it we
filter it we make assumptions based on
prior experience and the best you can do
is to to try and learn when and where
that's happening
and and try and counteract it you know
but it's not 100 possible you know
i mean i just i know that that's why
you've probably heard me say a few times
that it's like
well that's my perception and my
experience i'm not going to tell you
that's the way it is because
i don't believe that's the way it is
it's how i experienced it in that moment
and that's all i can articulate to you
you know you should also ask this person
and that person and trust your own
senses and and i think that in doing
that you get a better picture because
it's like oh they saw it a little
differently and i saw a little
differently and
so you kind of synthesize um you know
it's it's it's um
you know it's a fuzzy thing it's like
what it what is it possibly
um you know but but the people i see
fail are the ones who
who well not all of them but some of the
people i see fail are the ones who have
this rigid idea
that it works like this you do this you
do this you do this and that happens
and when one of those things fails to
produce it's like
you know hollywood hates me people are
evil
you know the system is rigged against me
um you know i'm unlucky i'm a victim
whatever
you know and that's just not empowering
and even
even if somebody really did do a thing
against you
even if somebody intentionally boned you
um
tripped you you know even if you met
somebody and it really was
rigged if you surrender to victimhood
you've given up your power you know even
if it's true
don't accept the role except
you know accept that you have the power
and and maybe you just don't go that way
maybe you go
this way or maybe you go that way again
that's the malleability it's like
it's like okay i thought that was gonna
work it didn't work i bashed my head i
tripped somebody either did or did not
deliberately
thwart me that's all beside the point
what am i gonna do now but i've just
seen people who have that rigidity of
thinking
you know or that assumption that
somebody else is persecuting them
again whether it's true or not really
doesn't matter
are you going to be empowered in that
moment to divert
or are you going to be stopped that's a
choice you have to make and
and i'm not going to judge anybody based
on their choice it makes me sad
if if that keeps them from what they
want
but it's their choice to make and i
respect that
so if someone is or isn't being kept
from
gatekeepers whomever from succeeding in
their mind
how do they say okay maybe that's true
maybe it's not but i'm not going to
accept that that's going to keep me down
i'm not going to ie accept the
victimhood
what are they doing to get i realize
each situation will be specific but
sort of what kind of mindset aside from
that what kind of action are they taking
to make sure they don't stay in that
victimhood well one of the things that
you can do
first of all is not consider yourself an
island
and by that i go back to my example
where i said you're standing there
and and i tell you something but what
did that person see what did you see
so don't keep it all here ask this
person
ask this person you know you've got a
team we're all a team we all have each
other's backs if you don't have friends
like that you've got the wrong
friends this is a business this is a
industry as an
artist you need your posse
you need the people who believe in you
you need the people who hold you
accountable to do the things you
say you will do and follow through and
will
gently call you when you don't
and you need the people that when you
are in that moment and you are stuck
and you feel that something has stopped
you or someone has stopped you or you
made a mistake
you can say i i just i don't know what
to do do you could
what do you think give me some advice
you know
and and you can do it with peers but
this is also where mentors
are really important reach out to the
people who are successful
doing what you need to do because you
know why
they've done it they know how to make it
happen
again they can't give you the roadmap
because you will not take the same path
you will not meet the same people
but bits and pieces of what they say
will apply
and they have had peers who've had
different experiences
they're going to be able to give you
advice and answers and again this is why
i say people should have
more than one mentor because every
you know everyone's going to give you
different advice and it doesn't mean
that one person's advice is better than
another's
it's all based on their life experience
but if you have a variety
you have a variety of possibilities you
have chocolate vanilla and strawberry
you know
they're all good you know but which one
is right in that moment for you
um so so that's what i would tell them
to do is just
is just is reach outside yourself you
know
seek advice consult your mentors consult
your friends
um you know google it put a put a post
on a
filmmaking board with complete strangers
here's my challenge what do you suggest
you know throw it out to the universe
and see what the universe
throws back maybe and maybe you have a
better idea than anything i said please
share that with me when you think of it
but um
you know to me there's always
possibilities there's
always there's always in life there's
always that thing we've overlooked
you know no matter what we consider you
know if if life gives us
a b and c there's always secret answer
number d
we may not know what it is you know but
we can look for it
we can go to our peers and our mentors
to try and figure it out
and there may also be you know secret
number secret answer e f
and g i don't know but i refuse
if if i look at the at the evidence
and it does not permit me to continue
toward my goal
then then then i declare that that's
incomplete evident
and and and just because i don't see it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
so rigidity kills careers
i don't think it kills i'm not going to
say i wouldn't be so absolutist to say
that rigidity kills creators
but i would say that that rigidity
hobbles options you know rigidity
limits your your choices
and and and if you are willing to give
up rigidity if you're willing to give up
being right in my case if you're
willing to give up being shyness or
being shy if you declare that this goal
of mine this
dream of mine is more important than
all those other things it opens
doors it gives you possibilities that do
not exist
if you say my shyness is more important
or my being right i have to be right
that's your prerogative you can be right
but you may not
get that thing you want
you